but oh I came in my mouth
what hey welcome back to Lucius to part
four for a eight oh god why is it
loading so slow what happened anyway how
you doing
tell me everything that's great gotta
have to interrupt you there cuz I'm all
bored I'm sorry but the story must
continue you filled in the burning cross
meant that Gilmore was already working
towards the seven trumpets
the boy was falling behind so I decided
to help him by stealing a truck filled
with pesticides are those barrels take
the boy straight to the third trumpet
leaving Isaac fulfilling the second
it would be through the nearby water
plant where wormwood poison a third of
the water sources and then would died
drinking it how nice that would even the
score between Lucius and Isaac putting
them both on the same level that's a
great way to kill people to be a race to
the finish between the two Grimm
brothers it seems very easy whoever
stood alone at the end with alone okay
best animation ever made hey here we are
yeah what's up and it was I was nearly
killed I can't believe this I thank God
you stopped in time sir
woman all right this game is so [ __ ]
weird but it's this looks kind of pretty
yeah the outdoors I remember that a
applier make a play and make a play
thank you make a play make a play oh god
what's happening what is going on what
are they doing dancing they're dancing
they're dancing they're dancing okay
there's a switch to the gate obviously
maybe we can mind-control someone to
open for us I get it there's a switch
how long is this cutscene gonna continue
I had to escape all right I'm gonna mind
control Jose Ramirez you gonna regret
the day you were not there horse saying
I do it I think we did it put some water
out here too
that was fun
hey buddy oh he has the key we need to
kill him how do we kill the Ramirez Oh
at the second trumpet sound accused
something like a great burning mountain
to the sea and wipes out a third of all
sea life and ships but there the oceans
will become blood oh damn for this was
Isaac's duty
we would have to work fast if you wanted
to get the same prestige she was
currently yeah that's pretty badass
we're not on that level we're not on
media or crashing down level yet oh god
it's really happening I'm scared so what
is this [ __ ] barrels flying in Shane
okay I'm murdering people and I don't
even know about that and I feel
responsible
oh god it's spreading throw it in its
face Rob stupid idiot no worry about it
don't panic it's gonna be okay
everything's gonna be all right it's
just a fire it's just a fire it's just a
fire buddy it's gonna be okay you're
just gonna die oh god it really flew
didn't he Ben course a bad day good day
we'll watch it happen water damage
minecraft my computer just exploded
that's amazing let's go in here
that's all we wanted oh oh sorry Jordan
didn't know you were pooping it's easy
covering his penis oh my god
ah I'm here how could he not notice me
how oblivious to your surrounding oh can
you be Oh
all right I need see what needs to be
done water we need water
hey Russ good mind if I take your pills
who else can we kill they sir
hey hey love you don't worry about it
well how that always works
I just a damn war man let's select fire
although this is the slippery slope oh
it works
the slippery still electrify justify the
electrified baby girl baby girl baby
girl water how nice set up in the garage
with the pills girls I need you pills
here
okay it's a little shortcut that guy
looks a little suspicious that guy looks
like something might have happened I
mean let me just take that away from me
did we not break this
can request is any any purpose of going
up here sure sweet air comforts
where the booze is confuse okay we got
some pills at least is anything to do
Wow damn we jump alright I guess we can
poison him cuz I'm I kind of want to try
and kill everyone
what do your breasts think huh would you
like some don't would you like some
don't eat the doughnuts Sebastian a
weapon you see panicking oh no don't
panic when you're dead that's never good
okay we need to do some [ __ ] here
voltage we got voltage it's got stuff in
there water that's what I wanted so now
that's shoving in a bunch of water and
the dead guys panicking we got water
plus electricity equals a maze right am
i right
am i right I'm
uh h2o
doesn't look like I have anything left
in it what about this one no why have I
been carrying around empty water cans
for so long
let's connect Oh God
I should be electrified right now but
I'm too handsome and beautiful and the
devil let's make it longer let's make a
water train to of Jeff dammit
are we out of water oh oh
I just just broke her [ __ ] know what it
wasn't me it wasn't me I swear to god it
wasn't me why don't you come here then
huh fight me in real life bruh fight me
in real life over here bruh
stupid idiot why don't you go to Steve
O'Neil if that is your real name
come here Steve oh god no what it's not
electrifying it's [ __ ]
Steve what happened to Steve Steve what
are you even doing Steve that is not how
you Steve man oh oh oh the penis get
electrified Wow amazing
yeah yeah yeah oh wait he had a key I
didn't even know we had to kill him
awesome
oh nice an easter egg inside oh that's
that's real classy
real classy guys hey rose should we
poison the coffee
I don't see why not Rosie thirsty you
thirsty how I am race I am thirsty for
some caffee hey that's the appropriate
sound of dying hey we are the Knights
who say eat well you [ __ ] you dead
how about that how about that how about
that how about that how about that how
about that how about a [ __ ]
we won't have one guy that we haven't
killed
Shrek the fire Shrek the fire
[ __ ] yeah
I thought I turned you upside down sorry
I have a problem and they're not afraid
to show it
no I mean I'm not afraid to [ __ ] I don't
know alright we broke so I just had to
click on it alright cool now we can go
here oh we can in my control that [ __ ]
Gemma Bell Isaac Morales
I will never seed dope hey buddy you
look good who looks like someone can
slide into that that'd be cool we should
try and use that at them but all for
later let's not go up there now
whoo that looks like it could drop on
someone that would be so sad Oh or we
could just smash someone's [ __ ] head
in how about that hey slippery slippery
hey Christian
no don't take me to the authorities
anything but the authorities Christian
no Christian no Christian no I'm just
kidding
[ __ ] you're Christian Christian
[ __ ] be slippery slow slippery
slippery sleep leads would be ashamed if
it slipped into these dammit you're
supposed to sleep in there [ __ ] slip
slippery slow
slippery slow slippery sleep let's save
this slippery slope for someone else
Oh God whenever you see the inside of
your face you get terrified purify
number 2 high voltage as well same shade
it seems like same puzzle okay I got it
I got it like five minutes ago Jesus
Christ
there we go this is what you get for
busting me you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god I
hate him what does he do water yeah yeah
oh my god I never seen such an annoying
little [ __ ] my leg I love that my leg I
understood but my leg inventory is full
oh my god I need to throw away some [ __ ]
we go
okay now we're out here now what are we
supposed to do here I move that back and
forth and it's must be like like a
bridge or some [ __ ] I'm all right I'm a
retro Cimarron
okay the bridge is open now when he just
throws something at that
ah my god Wow howhow is I supposed to
throw oh I came in my mouth what Oh see
now we're alone
well closer to me I thought I was being
able to I was MLG I was MLG don't hate
oh come on my last sandwich what I'm not
throwing away that yes come to Papa go
make the pepper senorita
oh my god so wonky I never want so hard
in my life crap did it good job rose
high-five
another restricted area oh sorry mate
didn't see you there don't mind me I'm
just poisoning your entire city and
murdering everyone that's some big deal
what is happening out there
she doesn't suspect a thing
Slippery sleeve slippery slip there so
sleepy sleepy sleepy sleepy [ __ ] love
watching the slip what the [ __ ] did I
just do I didn't mean to do that spot
get sup in the fence why did why did he
her friend go oh they're just chillin
bruh
someone died I don't know how how the
[ __ ] did they die she's sitting shocked
he died but how
oh he slid in oh that's awesome
that worked look how I killed him Hey
oh he's presenting himself another
pistol here
by the sound of third trumpet that is so
much effort just to do that
why was that so we leave the power plant
but hell oh the door could literally
have just [ __ ] Oh golly I ripped my
that's pretty good I enjoy that chapter
I enjoy that chapter a lot that's cool
let's do another one shall we
I got time babe I always get time for
you babe always sorry I can't
sorry lucious had poisoned the water
supply a horn started the sound is the
mark of the beast and this cleansing had
begun the boy was still gaining more
powers and that confirmed the path he
had taken towards evil he was sure he
was going to be eyes and feel more soon
enough
Isaac was able to bring forth the meteor
that plunged into the sea and lucious
was able to poison the water supplies
together their happy was devastating the
earth by shutting down the town's power
plant
lucious would bring complete darkness to
Ludlow and gain more momentum
I think Lucius is more badasses that's
my personal opinion
level 3 lights out baby girl who are you
you're not very nice aren't you we
really need to kill him don't we
what does that do
yeah baby now we can go in here what are
we doing here Bros what have we doin
Annie nothing I guess it looks like a
way to get up there well if it's fragile
we have to break it
boom boom bada bing bada BAM by the same
on your baby
shame on you don't worry baby I haven't
forgot about you did it Wow
breaking the power transformers did shut
down the lights from the town although
the fires in the village my visit
that's cute oh damn that's what you get
buddy we didn't need to kill him Danny
oh that was beautiful that was magic Oh
Mystica yes
yes I would have fallen yes oh wow but
breaking Betty do we we have to kill
everyone is that it there's one guy
missing there it is
level up baby finally [ __ ] finally oh
oh my god
minecraft that's ridiculous
all right price I'm gonna have to end
that there hope you enjoyed watching
thank you so much for leaving I'm like
I'm watching this series with me I'm
having a lot of fun with it so I hope it
wasn't enjoying it as well
I'll see bras in the final one next time
for now stay awesome and you'd have a
chance at new what the [ __ ] oh my God
he's so annoying
what is wrong with him ha to the lectern
in Luke that's how I roll that delegate
on the ladies